gonzaga's jalen suggs is headed to the  final four where a look to strengthen  his case even further  as a potential top three pick in the  2021 nba draft  he's led an undefeated veteran team as a  freshman  demonstrating the maturity toughness and  poise that scream leadership and  professionalism  he's a rare player capable of doubling  as both a star  and an energizer suggs pops under the  nba scouting lens for his burst  exploding downhill  his open floor passing vision dangerous  pull-up game and soft floater  but he's also a difference maker  defensively pressuring the ball and  anticipating offer  triple doubles are in this kid's future  stats and skills aside  nba scouts rave about the impact of the  19 year old's intangibles  which could elevate subs from productive  starter to winning franchise point guard